the wall street journal today notes
suddenly ecuadorans brazilians
nicaraguans venezuelans haitians and
cubans are turning up by the hundreds of
thousands
well of course we knew what made they
surprised by that over at the wall
street journal so why is this happening
now with the center for immigration
studies may have found their answer on
september 12th the mexican government
sent a massive migrant that had bottled
up for months in its southern states up
to the american border now this move
appears to have been done under the
cover
of mexico's independence week here now
is former secretary of state mike pompeo
mr secretary
uh good to see you tonight uh the biden
team has been trying to reboot
trump's remain in mexico policy
uh but mexico doesn't look like it's uh
it wants to play your reaction to all
this
well this is another example laura where
we left them a perfectly good plan we
left them a perfectly good plan in
afghanistan they turned it into chaos we
left them a perfectly good plan with
respect to how we handled our southern
border how we kept our sovereignty we
avoided a humanitarian crisis at the
border and they ripped that plan up too
and another now they're trying to get
back to it i am confident they'll try
and blame our administration for what's
happening as well in the same way they
did afghanistan but i think the american
people can see
these folks have implemented their ideas
poorly the humanitarian crisis is very
significant the burden this will place
on the united states for an awfully long
time is real the schools in these states
will have to now take these kids and put
them through school huge burdens that
will deny the the citizens that live
there and the kids that live there the
educations that they need
and make no mistake about it you
mentioned the wall street journal
article
every every person who's you know some
thinking maybe i should come we'll all
see that these haitians who often came
from central and south america they've
been there quite a while they didn't
they didn't just flee haiti in the last
week or two weeks after the earthquake
every single person who's been thinking
about coming to the united states
illegally now will see that there's a
green light that they're going to be
released inside the united states i
think we are at the very front end of
what will be a significant tidal wave of
illegal immigration we've seen it for
the first eight months of the bide
administration i suspect the next date
will only increase that
uh secretary pompeo what does this mean
for the definition i mean the meaning i
should say
of american independence and sovereignty
if a nation
is unwilling we're able to do it but if
we're unwilling by our elected leaders
to actually enforce our own borders
where does that leave us as a country
well it certainly makes our adversaries
happy to try to undermine our democracy
our republic you know you nailed it this
is about american sovereignty we have a
fundamental duty to protect our border
to know who's coming in and out not only
the who but the what the drugs the
traffickers
all all of the things that move across
that southern border today freely
we've got a democrat party who has
clearly been taken over by the open
borders crowd this is a this is a
dereliction of duty at the
at the most serious level american
sovereignty is at stake here and i think
the american people can see it i think
they can sense it and i am very
confident that the by administration
will hear loudly that they've got to
reverse these policies a good start
would be to put remain in mexico back in
place but an even more important idea
would be to make clear make clear that
we're going to adopt a policy that says
illegal immigration is simply going to
stop and if you come here unlawfully
you're going to be returned
secretary pompeo great to see you
tonight thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else